the first extended trailer for Pixar's
Cars 3 just dropped and it teases some
intriguing things for the second sequel
in the Cars franchise in this video I'm
going to take a look at some points you
might have missed in the extended look
trailer as well as some Easter eggs
which might impact the Pixar theory for
cars the trailer kicks off with the same
scenes from the teaser which saw
Lightning McQueen end up in a serious
crash that sends him spinning through
the air the new trailer also shows the
crash from some different angles and
with some crucial differences as the
trailer begins you'll notice is actually
daytime and if you look carefully you
can't really see any fully animated
faces and the spectator vehicles that
are looking on the colors are muted
everything has been dulled down and you
don't see any faces in the onlooking
RV's there's also a heartbeat and
breathing sound overlaid on top of the
action and all of these things together
point to the fact that something beyond
the obvious is going on here ok let's
jump forward to later in the trailer
where we see the crash from another
angle the crash happens at the Los
Angeles International Speedway in both
of the scenes but here is actually
nighttime with the racetrack lit by the
stadium lights also the unlocking
spectators and RVs are properly animated
with proper cars faces and eyes so why
the difference well it seems likely that
the first crash scene that happens
during the day with a dulled and gray
background is actually a dream sequence
or flashback that Lightning experiences
later in the movie we know that after
the crash lightning has to retrain with
Cruz Ramirez to find how he's going to
get his form back so this could be a
nightmare that lightning suffers during
his recovery process there are also some
nice T's as to what we might expect from
lightnings recovery including a couple
of new looks and paint jobs during his
crash lightning is still sporting more
or less the same look from cars one in
the beginning of cars two with his
classic Rusty's logo on the back but in
the latest scene where he visits an old
disused Speedway track with Cruz Ramirez
we can see he's had a new paint job he's
now got a sort of souped up much larger
Rusty's logo on his side and another on
his back end he also has Lightning
McQueen emblazoned in bright fluorescent
letters just above his side windows and
later in a pit stop seen the Rusty's
logo has changed again reducing back
down in size but still different to the
style from the first two movies
Jackson's storm is clearly
new champion on the block and we can see
him collecting an award presumably the
Piston Cup and all the wild lightning is
looking on from the corner his number
looks like 20 but the design has
inserted a small point between the 2 and
the 0 which feels like a subtle
reference to the fact that storm
represents the upcoming new generation
of racecars so he's kind of version 2.0
and also the symbol on the side of
Jackson storm is appropriately enough
based on the international hurricane
symbol it's been tweaked and stretched
and color matched with his other blue
colors to give him a sleek look the
trailer also flashes through some of the
tech that is powering the new upstart
racer the screen show how he can change
his tire pressure
according to track conditions and also
which race trackies on and he's also
perfected his skills and speed with
access to a racing simulator there's a
neat by-and-large
Easter Egg which you can spot as a track
sponsor at one of the speed waves and
this could be a further clue that ties
the cars franchise into John new grones
Pixar theory remember BNL as the
corporation in Wally basically enabled a
pollution of the planet and sent humans
away from Earth while it attempted to
clear it up the Pixar theory suggests
that cars takes place after humans leave
the planet and before a time hundreds of
years later when the events of wall-e
take place and the presence of by and
large as a corporate sponsor
incarcerations the corporation is still
very much active on earth at this time
there is some other new sponsors teased
in the trailer - including the grand old
oil company and frost our air filters
while Dinoco is clearly still the
sponsor of the piston cup series and is
also a new Thunder Hollow Speedway where
there seems to be some pretty full-on
Mad Max style racing going on so far
neither lightnings trusty pal may turn
or his girlfriend Sally have appeared in
any trailers but the characters are
confirmed to appear in cars 3 and were
included in footage shown at the Detroit
Auto Show so guys what did you think of
the extended look trailer were there any
other Easter eggs you spotted and what
do you think about the look of
lightnings new rival Jackson's storm I'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
do please hit that thumbs up button
share and subscribe and you can check
out more of my Pixar videos right here
on cars 3 finding dory and inside out
thanks for watching and see you next
time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers